[Music]
the easiest way to treat dry skin
is to spread on some skin cream it
rejuvenates the skin cells and acts as a
protective barrier
this is particularly important in the
winter when cold outdoor air and indoor
heating
suck the moisture out of your skin
if you have dry skin it's wise to keep a
good supply of skin cream
on hand
[Music]
it's not just dry air that makes skin
flaky and itchy
cancer treatments can also dry out the
skin along with other medical conditions
like diabetes
[Music]
the first ingredient is steric acid it's
a wax derived from palm tree oil
the next ingredient is refined lanolin
it's blended with isopropylmyristate a
natural oil that helps soften the
stearic acid
these ingredients make up what's called
the oil soluble phase of the recipe
workers heat the stearic acid until it
liquefies
then add the blend of lanolin and
isopropylmyristate
and keep heating while the oil phase is
heating
they prepare the water-soluble phase of
the recipe the first ingredient is
glycerin
derived from a vegetable source such as
corn
they heat and mix it then add purified
water
they continue heating the mixture to
just below the boiling point
add a floral fragrance then pump the oil
phase into the bottom of the tank
it blends in with the water phase while
naturally rising to the top
they gradually lower the temperature
this makes the mixture creamy and bright
white
[Music]
after an hour of mixing the skin cream
is ready
they pump it out of the mixing tank to
supply tanks that feed the filling line
[Music]
this company packages its skin cream in
jars for body cream
and tubes for hand cream
workers unpack boxes of plastic jars and
line them up on a conveyor belt that
feeds the labeling machine
each jar passes a photo eye sensor this
sensor triggers the machine to spin
the jar at the same speed as the
adhesive label coming off the roll
[Music]
workers place the label jars onto a
turntable that feeds the filling machine
two single file lanes each lead to three
nozzles
the machine fills up to 125 jars per
minute
depositing 12 ounces of skin cream into
each jar
the two lanes of filled jars merge as
they approach the capping machine
the caps come down a chute to the
machine's carousel
a device called a timing screw correctly
positions each
jar to receive a lid
[Music]
the lower part of the machine holds the
jar steady as an arm secures the lid in
place
the next station on the line applies an
adhesive label onto the cap
the jars of body cream are ready for
sale this factory also packages hand
cream in a tube
that you can keep in your purse or
pocket
[Music]
a mechanical arm places the tubes on a
turntable
cap side down the bottom of each tube is
open and ready for filling
[Music]
a nozzle squirts two ounces of skin
cream into the tube
then the machine heats the open end to
soften the plastic
clamps it shut then cools the plastic to
a solid state
when you rub the cream on your skin the
key ingredients glycerin and lanolin
pack a one-two punch glycerin is
hygroscopic
meaning it draws water from the air to
the skin
smooths the skin forming a protective
film to lock in the moisture
you